please welcome the dynamic duo of the
interior design world nate berkus and
jeremiah brent
i drew i'm so happy to see you guys i
didn't realize that you guys
were the first same-sex couple to get
married carrie bradshaw style
at the new york public library how crazy
is that
in their hair it was amazing it was a
big deal
and we also wanted a place where our
kids could always go back and visit
so you know what's more iconic than the
new york public library and
i don't think you can get married on the
top of the eiffel tower so that was
choice number one this show that i was
just watching
i'm mad that the clip ended all i want
to do is like cozy
up and watch this show did you guys have
fun doing the competition
no i mean what a horrible
horrible experience in georgia with bugs
the size of my head
it was a journey it was quite a journey
that i'm glad
we had we learned a lot we did we
actually loved the design portion of it
i mean
each of the team had the same budget to
renovate these homes but the homes
aren't for
anybody and both of us really love
connecting with the homeowner and really
understanding their story and the
history of what matters to them and we
incorporate that into the design
decisions that we make so
this was very freeing because we tried
to give the house
a soul but it wasn't for anyone it was
like the people we made up in our minds
oh that is such an interesting
perspective i wouldn't have thought of
it that way because
i do love the rock the block show um so
i'm really excited to hear from you guys
the tip of the top of like the mountain
in
design and hear about you guys
transforming a blank space
into something special um one of our
vff's is actually looking
for some advice about her great room
please welcome tiara
hi hi hi hi tiara i'm so happy you're
here
thank you i'm excited to be here take it
away what is your question
i have a great room that consists of a
kitchen
a dining room and a living room all in
one big space
how can i add decor to give each area
its own separate look
now i do like things with metal and i do
have hardwood floors so
would that work together yeah i mean
first of all
it's a great floor plan you get tons of
light it looks like and all those
windows so it's a really beautiful space
the good news is that you've got the
dining room table and the
fixture is in the right spot so ideally
what you want to do is you want to
divide it into zones
um and that means that you need to be a
little bit more artful
about your furniture placement like
right now your sofa
stairs at the dining room table and the
tv's over the mantel
so let's switch that around right yeah
so what we've done here
is we've really pulled the room out
you've got this really beautiful sofa
um facing the fireplace i hope you think
that stuff is beautiful we
we designed it yes that's part of our
living collection
audrey but it's timeless and it's
beautiful and we've kind of
paired it with this really beautiful
chest that's in front of the fireplace
which is a great moment
for one person or if you've got a couple
people over
really kind of opening the space up we
put a bookcase um
in front it's actually a hutch meant for
a dining room um
that could house the tv and that tv
could be moved on that wall
and then this idea of creating like
those
four parts of a square the sofa facing
the fireplace
a pair of really comfortable chairs
facing the wall
and then the day bed that jeremiah was
mentioning but you'll notice like
our instinct was to put the dining room
table and chairs where you had it as
well
also i noticed that you put a rug under
the living room which to me just always
visually
immediately gives a zone in itself
i think it looks beautiful um a generous
rug and the rule
you can see it should go either
completely underneath all the furniture
or
three quarters of the way under the
furniture so the back legs sit off
another thing i just have to chime in is
make sure you put your curtains
like a foot out from your windows
because otherwise you're going to block
all your lighting
and to me that's a cardinal rule go out
a foot on either side and then when you
open all the fabric that's covering it
you have your whole windows
exactly you guys also have a lighting
tip i am all ears for this because
lighting changes everything
um you'll notice we added a mirror over
the fireplace we added sconces
a different fixture over the um over the
dining room table
and we mixed it because the furniture
that we were looking at has a lot of
rich textures
so the lighting can have a shine
it can have different you can mix
metallics that was one of your questions
i know
yes but um always mix metals and you
want to be able to control the mood
in the space so we've got a table lamp
um the cord runs underneath the rug and
gets plugged into the wall
there's a floor lamp um there's little
sconces next to the fireplace
but you want to be able to control the
mood you don't want overhead lighting on
necessarily if you're having a intimate
chat
or if you're watching television or
reading now nate and jeremiah you also
added a bunch of final touches
um let's take a look at that oh gosh
that looks so you can really see the
space starts to come alive here the tv
is concealed it's not really the focal
point of the room anymore
um but it's still fully functioning you
know for us greenery
branches pottery that is always kind of
that that final layer to any space and
it really brings that outdoors in
um and it really makes the space really
evolved and again like people are living
there and it brings that warmth
tierra were you saying that you're kind
of starting from scratch here
like you don't have a ton of stuff
you're starting you want to start fresh
correct i just moved and this is my old
furniture and i wanted to just start
over
so this is almost like a clean sleep and
nate and jeremiah
um also want to help you start
personalizing your home
so they're going to give you a 500 uh
voucher to their newly launched
collection for
living spaces thank you
you're welcome yeah and then we're gonna
give you also a thousand dollar gift
card from flower home
um and there's just you know just start
just hand pick everything whether
it's from the three of us or when you're
shopping on your own
drew's right i mean you know a clean
slate
is such an amazing opportunity and you
know if we can add to her advice i would
say resist the urge just to buy stuff to
check the box
um you know just because something's on
sale and
no payments till 2050 and whatever
if you don't love it don't buy it every
decision matters it really does
i can't thank you enough tiara so much
for being on the show
and nate and jeremiah be sure to
rock the block on hgtv march 8th
at 9 pm that's when it'll be premiering